if there are questions and answers we'll
make them available document link to our
webinars page which is where all of our
courses of webinars are and the
materials and the you know the slides
and the Q&A is going to be available on
our FTP site as well and that a
compressed URL right there will take you
to that material so I'm going to turn
this over to Evan thank you Peter
hello everybody it's nice to see we have
a nice audience out there so today I'm
going to talk to you about pubchem as a
source of laboratory chemical safety
information if you are not aware of what
Pupkin is as a resource I'll just give
you a quick overview where we're
centered here at the National Center for
Biotechnology information and we contain
the chemical content that is found
within NCBI within the resource called
Park M this is our home page I'd
encourage you to explore it especially
the services tab at the top there and so
that way you can have a greater
familiarity with resource our overall
goal is to be an open archive of public
information and our key mission has
evolved slightly as a function of time
but what we really aim to do is provide
the biological role and function of
chemical substances and Health and
Safety is definitely within that scope
pubchem as a resource the contents
change on a daily basis and so if that
is not there one day you can check back
you might find something the next so the
hope is that from this webinar you'll be
able to understand three primary things
that pubchem compound is a source of
information for your laboratory chemical
safety data and the hope here is that
you can understand the LCSs the pipe
chemists laboratory chemical safety
summary that its source and content and
where you can access this information
but also how you can use an axis
relative to laboratory safety prudent
practices
there's quite a number of reasons for
this webinar to have to be important for
many people for one there are three
hazmat responses to laboratories every
week
academic research laboratories account
for about half of all hazmat responses
to laboratories in the US and teaching
labs count for about 10% education is a
third highest had mass hazmat response
sector since 2010 the Chemical Safety
Board has produced two major reports on
chemical safety incidents in research
and teaching laboratory settings these
are based on a classroom methanol fire
in 2006 and the series of research live
events from 2008 to 2011 urban is an
ongoing series of laboratory hazmat
event since then and secure at chemical
accidents which have really called into
question the the traditional laboratory
health and safety paradigm don't make
mistakes when you won't have accidents
in a question and learn more to concern
about the safety culture of laboratories
and this has been specifically addressed
and reports by the ACS and National
Research Council so chemical health and
safety data sources are really blessed
in many ways and having so many
different data sources available this
however presents an issue in that there
can be gaps or errors and information if
all the information was available you
know will decisions made by chemists
change every scientist you can think of
you know they may not be aware of the
various sources of information and I
just presented here you know just a
small fraction of those that are
available a couple into this the fact
that laboratory chemical safety
information is evolving there's been a
recent transition for material data
safety sheets the so called MSDS to the
globalized global harmonization system
GHS safety data sheets otherwise known
as SDS and this was a really a major
step forward in part because it provided
a standardization of the information
content that would be available
this has been further evolving through
the national research count national
research council NRCS put in practices
in the laboratory handling and
management of chemical hazards
publication it was really a major step
forward for laboratory chemical users
and describe issues of scale related to
laboratory use of chemicals it provided
a set of properties and a format for to
be used and the pubchem LCSs is more or
less mirrored that content as a subset
of information that is available within
pubchem as a whole it includes various
types of hazard and safety information
such as flammability tox toxicity
exposure limits exposure symptoms first
aid handling and cleanup this evolution
is important technically but also
culturally because chemists have been
traditionally disappointed by the
limited value of the MSDS so what this
you can imagine is you know the LCSs
enables all the available health and
safety information or subset a useful
subset of this and making it available
for ready use one of the reasons why
this is important relative to pubchem is
that it provides a fair degree of
breadth of information and really helps
to move chemical safety information
resources from the limitations of the
20th century paper media to leverage
21st century chemical information
technologies we go one step further than
the traditional SDS that you might
otherwise get via GHS by including other
information such as specific reactivity
information of the chemical with other
reagents so if you look at a typical
property such as boiling point you can
then see who is providing what
information from various authoritative
resources a common hazmat rule is that
three sources have to agree on a
property before an operational decision
should be made based on that property
so with pubchem is collection of safety
information allows for a direct
comparison of authoritative
the sources you can access the LCSs and
pubchem quite readily from any page that
has is content you'll see a safety
summary link inside the page which will
then give you a laboratory chemical
safety summary data view for that same
record but the content is reformatted in
such a way that is more in line with the
GHS SDS sheet but also to make for easy
comparisons the information content
there's a fair bit of chemical safety
data content inside pubchem what you're
looking at here is a data view from the
pubchem classification browser where
we're showing a classification tree for
our Pupkin compound table contents so
basically for the various information
pieces inside pubchem you can see that
we have over a hundred thousand records
with safety and hazard information
content the numbers you see here are the
number of chemical compound records
inside pubchem that contains certain
types of property or property types so
for instance for GHS classifications
there are about one hundred and two
thousand chemicals that have this type
information content in addition you can
see that or in contrast stability and
reactivity information content is lonely
limited to about 5,700 records most of
this coming through the National Library
of medicines hazardous substance
databank hsdb system so in terms of
global harmonization you might find that
different data sources provide different
degrees of GHS classification nice thing
here is that pubchem has provided the
subset of the GHS information contents
available perhaps important - this is
the information content that comes from
European chemicals agency through the
reach efforts that they have there in
Europe one thing that you'll notice is
that pubchem records will aggregate that
content so if you see here for acetone
there's 78 different note
vacations provided by over 3500
different companies but you can see that
when you compare this information
content between the different sources
some data sources such as that from the
the Japanese night data source includes
additional GHS hazard codes that you
don't find for other records so in part
by being able to compare these different
data sources and then going back to the
original data source to find out why
perhaps that they have selected these
different hazard codes it can provide
you more informed information in terms
of decisions however there are some
issues with some of the information
content that you can get through pubchem
in part because a chemical structure
record could have multiple forms of an
entity associated with it
as we see here in the case of
formaldehyde there are over 4,000
companies providing different
notifications and we had to provide a a
we aggregated this information content
and lets you know what percentage of
these notifications that are coming from
these companies for reporting various
types of codes hazard codes they may
correspond to different forms of the
same entity that is of importance to
your use case or may not be important to
your use case so you have to examine
them and see what are the different
records and types information content
that's available a neat thing here is
that pubchem opens up new opportunities
for using safety data in a practical way
by giving safety information in a very
customized form via data streams in fact
you can download the entire content in
this case you you can go to the pubchem
FTP site and you can download a gzip
compressed XML file that has the entire
content of what pubchem knows relative
to El CSS and we update this on a daily
basis we also provide extensive
provenance and from a
where you can explore our different data
sources and for instance limit them to
annotation for sources so out of the 522
data sources in pubchem today there's 57
that provide annotation content and you
can examine each of these individual
records so for instance for the European
chemicals agency you can see that we
they provide us various types
information content such as GHS
classification information and you can
then download that content in a data
stream that may be helpful and
informative
for your purposes you can also download
this information content on the fly the
earlier pubchem table of contents also
lists the information sources so that
you can see how many chemical records
have information from particular data
sources so in summary the pubchem
Laboratory chemical safety summary
contains basic information raw data
GHS classifications and more that are
important for you to make informed
choices or to locate information sources
to make informed choices it's also an
important piece of the ongoing evolution
of laboratory chemical safety
information that helps you move away
from paper and more towards a simple way
for you as a human to read that content
compare that content and to work with it
in a computer readable way in part
because it's downloadable in bulk and we
have quite a breadth of data over a
hundred thousand chemicals but also a
fair bit of depth for a number of
entities which have other properties and
information content that's important it
also provides an extensive provenance
trail that allows you to understand
which data sources that are
authoritative and how we do the data
linking so the work that you saw here
today wasn't just my work it was from
the various members of the upcam group
but also in part due to our
collaborators especially a shout out to
lea McEwen and Ralph Stewart but also
our software collaborators including
next move software Daniel Lowe and
others but
so our prep comdata contributors and
collaborators this work was also in
sported in part by the intramural
research program here at NIH and I've
included several different references
here for folks to get additional
information about what was presented
today
and I'd be happy to entertain any
questions at this point in time thank
you
thanks Evan we do have one question in
the questions pod it says you mentioned
that the LCSs collection is updated
daily do you know how rapidly does GHS
information change for a particular
chemical so in most cases the LCSs
information is not changing on a daily
basis however errors that people make in
the LC SS could be updated any time it's
having that update cycle but also the
having the inclusion of content on a
regular basis allows us to keep up to
date and with other changes that are
made throughout the information
Enterprise but as new information
content is made available it then gets
added and then one can access that
additional information content ok we
have another question in the aggregated
data for example when there were 73
sources for the hazard code how do you
delve into the 73 that were aggregated
in other words how would you see the
original reports so this is a rephrase
what I order in terms of question can
you access the original information
content that was used to make up the
LCSs inside pubchem yes you can go back
to the original authoritative
information data source all the URLs
that where the information content came
from is available to you in fact when
you start to see things that are
different between different
authoritative sources it should
immediately raise a red flag that you
should go back and look at what they're
talking about in terms of what aspect of
that chemical or whether it could be a
different phase of the material gas or
solid versus liquid or a mixture form of
that in some cases another question this
is the evolution of the SPS do you see
LCSs becoming a standard for chemical
reporting through suppliers well I would
say that
pliers oftentimes have a a legal
responsibility for the information
content they provide and while LCSs
could become part of the information
data streams that you see from suppliers
that legal requirement may provide some
degree of separation as to what they
want to report and why Sarah version
history tracking available that is can
we know what information was available
in December 2016 compared to today no
not in the case of the annotations
provided to pubchem if it was in the
archival part of pubchem the answer
would be yes however annotations such as
these are not archived so you would have
to go back to the original data source
to see what information they provided or
to regularly download and compare the
LCSs content that is found within
pubchem okay here's the one that will
put you on the spot I think it's a good
idea if you feel like doing it can you
do a demo to show them how to get to
this on the webpage sir so you can just
type in pubchem in this case I'm going
to Google and you can go directly to
pubchem you can search for a record all
I don't know would be a good one
acetone it says a search within pubchem
you notice that it finds a number of
different data sources that are
available you can click on that record
and you can see that the laboratory
Chemical Safety summary is is right
there you can click on it and access
what you see there the neat thing is
that you have a download button you can
always see the data use to display the
page you can download it in different
file formats and you can learn how to
get these to pull them for a set of
structures just by looking at the Earl
that you see there this information is
in JSON format which is not for humans
to interpret but for computers so if you
had a programmatic access route that
you're interested in you have access to
both of these if you wanted to go to pop
chem you can go to the pubchem FTP site
you can go to the compound records in
the extras folder and you can access the
LC
says content directly right here we're
not making people too dizzy by moving
around too quick there's a
classification tree inside pubchem you
can go down to the pubchem compound
table of contents and you can see the
various information that's available
there in fact you can take a query that
you had in this case it did acetone just
a moment ago I can pull that record in
and it will do one on the fly and we see
the the various keyword searches of
acetone there were over 2,200 records
but over 1400 of these have some type of
annotation content of these we can see
that there is safety and hazard
information for 223 it's around some of
the elements of my screen here we can
figure out how many have GHS content and
I'm going to just do a turn off records
that don't have any information we can
see various types of information that is
helpful and useful for our purposes we
see 216 have an LC SS data page we can
look for stability and reactivity
content so if we're interested in those
that have reactivity incompatibilities
you can click on that in this case we
can see which records have it we have
ethanol methanol various other types of
Records neat thing that may be worth
exploring is that you can expand the
table of contents and you can find other
types information that you may be
interested so you wanted to know about
solubilities or in the case of
reactivities and compatibilities you can
scroll to that section I think I hit on
a number of the things that were of
interest I'd be happy to entertain any
additional questions it does another
question in here that I don't know
whether I understand it completely we
noted that when we download g8 GHS from
different sources the file is the same
so II regulations is the same as file as
the Knights emc and it was something
here for one of the pubchem urls when
you download information content by data
source you're downloading all data for
that data stream for all sources so you
can filter that out dynamically because
it's a computer accessible data stream
so you basically the download at this
point is not based on data source we
could make it that way but is how it was
designed at this point in time okay I
think we need to wrap it up we're about
at time if there are any questions that
we didn't get to in the questions pod
we'll be sure to address those and the
questions and answer document that's
going to be posted with the slides and
everything else on the FTP site or
remember that's going to be linked to
the webinars and courses page so thanks
everybody for coming
talk to you next time
you